what do you do when you fall off track
I'm going to answer that question in
today's episode of ask Evan sorry mr.
got a question for one of my loyal
youtube viewers and TGIM mastermind
members psyched to go who asked could
you talk about how to overcome feelings
of edginess
or dread like for example days when you
don't have enough sleep or you wake up
past your intended time and don't get to
do your morning routine anymore but when
you are worrying about something outside
your work I really like the mindset
stuff this is a fantastic question and I
think this really depends on your
personality I know for me when I miss my
morning routine I have a high likelihood
of my whole day blowing up on me and so
I'm gonna share with you the three
things that I do that hopefully can help
you with your process number one is try
to do something valuable this is
probably the hardest thing for me but if
I've missed my morning routine or I get
interrupted a lot you know I get that's
why I don't have phone calls anymore
because I don't want people interrupting
me in my day I still try to get back on
track and try to get back into a
schedule where I can provide some value
for that day this makes it really easy
when I've committed to somebody else so
for example on Wednesday I do all my
videos I've got Jason here coming to see
me and so I have to do videos on
Wednesday you know if I miss my water
routine Jason's still coming at noon I
still got the videos up I know you guys
are expecting them and so does that
external pressure to keep going on
Thursdays I have my meetings of
interviews coffee appointments phone
calls and all of those again I'm not
gonna miss because I've committed to
somebody else so when I've committed to
somebody else I'm much more likely to
get back on track where if I haven't
committed to somebody else and I don't
have anything to like pressuring me
right away I find a lot harder honestly
to get back on schedule and so my my
trick I guess is in that case try not to
fall off schedule in the first place
because I know how important my schedule
is for me personally I try to keep to it
as much as possible and try to design a
life where I don't have interruptions I
try to run what I call a no crisis
business
I hate being reactionary I hate playing
defense and just reacting to people's
problems instead I like being proactive
and attacking the new challenges are
that are ahead of me and you know
planning my schedule out as I want it to
be instead of being instead of reacting
to what other people want me to do
number two is explore something new what
I find is that if my day has blown up on
me and I just can't get back on track
and I haven't committed anybody else for
the day instead of just playing League
of Legends all day I'll try to just try
something new I'll try to break out take
on a project I haven't tried before look
at my list of ideas and try to tackle
those just try to get in that space - to
get me out of thinking that the whole
day is gone I find this is me personally
that if I try to get back on track with
a day that I've known is already kind of
falling sideways then I'm not committed
to those projects as much where instead
I try something new and totally
different I get energized again I have
passion again I can attack it with with
new eyes and I'm ready to go and do it
so if my day goes and blows up on me
then I try to go and find something new
to work on that still adds value but
maybe wasn't what I already scheduled
for the day and number three is start on
time tomorrow and that may seem really
basic but if you threw away your day you
woke up late you missed some
appointments you didn't get the work
done that you needed you goofed off and
went rips ticking all day or whatever it
was and you feel like crap at the end of
the day thinking man I didn't get
anything done today because you missed
your morning start then start on time
tomorrow right get a good night's sleep
set that alarm you wake up and whatever
the first thing is that you do for me
it's a gratitude exercise that I go
through whatever that first thing is
that you do start with that right away
as soon as you wake up and get your day
off to a good start the next day around
so those are my tips and again it's
highly personalized to me because the
schedule is so important for me to be a
happy and successful person I know a lot
of people are way more flexible than I
am and so again I encourage you to
design a life and a lifestyle that fits
who you are and allows you to leverage
your strengths so I'd love to know from
what do you do when you fall off track
when your date explodes on you you wake
up late whatever reason your day isn't
going as you would planned how do you
handle it I'd love to hear from you in
the comments below thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon